Democrats outraged by the recent
argument made by Trump's lawyers that
the president seeking foreign help to
win reelection is in the public's
interest say he may as well be coronated
King with Mitch McConnell holding the
crown and the Republicans holding his
train this is wrong
dead wrong and and you don't need to be
a constitutional scholar to understand
that what we have seen over the last
couple days is a descent into
constitutional madness senators serving
as jurors in Trump's impeachment trials
submitted their final questions Thursday
read aloud by Supreme Court Chief
Justice John Roberts but he declined a
question submitted by Republican Senator
Rand Paul
the presiding officer declines to read
the question as submitted because it
reportedly named the whistleblower whose
report kicked off Trump's impeachment
Republicans accused the whistleblower of
being a democratic operative helping the
party house Trump that is the most
massive election interference we've ever
witnessed its domestic election
interference the Democrats say
Republicans who are the Senate majority
are playing with fire if they blindly
support a president who has floated
constitutional norms Democrats say at
the very least senators should seek to
hear all available evidence it is
certainly in their interest and the
president's interest that we have a fair
trial a trial without truth without key
evidence without witnesses and documents
would render the president's acquittal
meaningless Democrats want to call
former national security adviser john
bolton to testify the White House is
trying to stop him from publishing his
upcoming book that reportedly bolsters
the case Trump abused his power now all
eyes are on the moderate Republican
senators who will be the swing vote on
whether to call witnesses or to
immediately end the trial with trumps
all but certain acquittal
Heidi Joe Castro al Jazeera Washington